momento de hablar de economía en france
24 y por ello le doy la bienvenida a mi
compañero jorge hurtado porque empezamos
hablando de eeuu porque hoy se
presentaron los datos de inflación en
este país así en los precios ahí se
dispararon en octubre siguiendo una
tendencia de inicio de año pese que las
autoridades han señalado que este efecto
es transitorio el índice de precios al
consumo subió el mes pasado hasta el 6,2
por ciento la mayor subida anual en 31
años y que supone que la tendencia
seguirá así al menos hasta inicios del
próximo año la inflación andrés aumentó
casi un punto en octubre el doble del
registrado en septiembre las causas el
incremento de los precios de la gasolina
y la alimentación así como el aumento de
las rentas y los bloqueos en la cadena
de suministro algunos analistas añaden
la presión en el mercado laboral donde
la aguda escasez de trabajadores está
haciendo subir los salarios de esta
escasez limita la producción de materias
primas y dificulta trasladar los bienes
de las fábricas a los consumidores
asimismo andrés los millones de dólares
de ayudas gubernamentales por la
pandemia avivaron la demanda de bienes
dejando las cadenas de suministro
sobrecargadas un efecto que aún se
mantiene con los puertos a tope la casa
blanca como reserva federal han
insistido en que la inflación caerá una
vez que los cuellos de botella de la
oferta comiencen a aliviarse pero ayer
el secretario de transporte admitió que
esto persistirá al menos hasta que
termine la pandemia la inflación está
haciendo que los consumidores
estadounidenses compren más en tiendas
de descuento el gasto de las tiendas de
descuento aumentó un 65% la semana
pasada en comparación con 2019 y un 21%
respecto a la semana anterior según
facto es una empresa que hace el
seguimiento de estas transacciones con
tarjetas de crédito y débito porque la
inmobiliaria china ever ground cayó en
un nuevo impago así que este miércoles
debía pagar 148 millones de dólares de
intereses de 3 bonos pero no lo hizo uno
de los acreedores de estos bonos la
consultora alemana dmsa dijo en un
comunicado que no recibió parte del
dinero y que prepara una demanda de
bancarrota contra everland con una deuda
superior a los 3 mil millones de dólares
el gigante chino ever grand es la
compañía más endeudada del mundo la
crisis de esta empresa ya contagio al
sector inmobiliario chino llevando a que
otras compañías cayeran en
incumplimiento de pago de deuda en china
el sector inmobiliario para que no
tenemos unidades representa más del 20
por ciento del producto interno bruto el
temor por la posible quiebra de esta
inmobiliaria radica en que afecta a los
mercados globales la reserva federal de
eeuu reconoció el lunes que la situación
genera riesgos para el sistema
financiero de ese país y para declarar
la bancarrota la misma empresa o sus
acreedores deben presentar una demanda
de insolvencia en los tribunales algo
que para muchos analistas podría suceder
en tan solo días y bruselas multará a
google cuenteros porque bueno el
tribunal general de la unión europea
confirmó la multa de 2.400
2004 124 millones de euros que la
comisión europea impuso a google en 2017
la multa fue impuesta por un supuesto
abuso de posición dominante al favorecer
a su sistema operativo frente a los de
la competencia la corte rechazó el
recurso que interpuso la compañía y dio
la razón a la comisión europea en su
análisis de que google supuestamente
violó la libre competencia al haber
otorgado un lugar privilegiado a su
servicio comparativo en la página de
resultados de búsqueda además de esta
multa bruselas impuso otras dos por
abuso de posición dominante una de ellas
es de 1.490 millones de euros y en la
otra es de
4.343 millones de euros por utilizar el
sistema operativo android o por realizar
este sistema operativo en los
dispositivos móviles para reforzar la
posición del buscador porque momento de
conocer los indicadores arrancamos con
walker que cerró en rojo afectado por el
aumento de los precios al consumo las
acciones europeas cerraron el miércoles
en máximos históricos tras los buenos
resultados de los sectores de medios de
comunicación y de energía y en
latinoamérica la bolsa cerraron mixta la
bolsa mexicana desanimada principalmente
por la inflación local que también los
afecta y nuestra cifra del día la cifra
del día bueno tiene que ver con la house
oeste es una startup latinoamericana del
sector inmobiliario que dijo que
aceptará bitcoin para las transacciones
de bienes raíces el portafolio de la
aplicación que permite comprar viviendas
es de 80 mil propiedades que ahora
podrán ser compradas en esta cripto
moneda pues que muchas gracias por la
información económica aquí en france 24
y ustedes también muchas gracias por
sintonizarnos continúen con todas
nuestros programas
i
[Música]